(audience applauding)
- You are a vision ma'am.
- Oh thank you.
- With these cute hose underneath-
- Listen, I feel-
- [Kelly] Peeking through.
- You know, when you feel tired
and when you feel crazy,
you should wear the cutest outfit.
- Absolutely.
It's lovely to meet you.
And have you ever met Helen? I don't know-
- No, never before. You're
an icon and a legend.
- You're an icon and a legend.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Nice to meet you.
- I know you walking out. I
was like, all right, inferior.
- [Helen] Can you and I go
run and change super quick?
We'll be right back.
- Wait, we're gonna be right back
and we're gonna look so cool.
Actually you look rad in
that, so rock and roll.
- Thank you.
- Well we just had your
husband, Joshua Jackson on.
- I know.
- I did not know that we were
gonna hit it off so well.
Even family-wise, talking
about our past and stuff.
Super cool guy.
- He told me that he had the best time-
- [Kelly] Oh really?
- On the show with you, yes.
- He is so cool. Anyway, I love, and then,
there was a picture of you both
and I was like, married up Joshua.
- [Jodie] He did.
- You are a beautiful man, but damn.
So is it true though, the Pharrell story?
You were backstage at a
concert and he was like
what are you doing with your life?
Why are you not on camera?
- It is true, it's true.
The infamous Pharrell story. Yes.
- [Kelly] He's so kind. He's so nice
- He's so kind.
He was so kind and so enthusiastic.
And it was just this
moment for me where I was
here's this absolute stranger
who's just believing in me.
Why not just take a chance on myself?
And so it was kind of
this moment that sort of
blew the wind underneath
my wings, you know?
And he introduced me to someone
who gave me my first jobs, Hype Williams.
Because I moved to LA
I didn't have any money
cause I didn't save any money.
And I was just like
I don't know how we're gonna survive here,
but we're gonna figure it out.
And then eventually I
went around to agencies
and open calls and, and found an agency.
And shortly after I signed
with my first agency,
I got my first campaign,
which was a Levi's campaign.
And it was just all
these things that were,
okay this person who like
sent me on this path,
now the universe is affirming
I am on this right path.
Because you never know the messages
that are coming from the universe
or that are coming from God.
You never know where who's
gonna be the best for that message.
- Exactly. That's why kindness matters and
(audience applauding)
Being cool with people and
you know change people's lives
and that ends up changing yours.
- I remember auditioning for a play
that I really wanted and didn't get,
but the director said If I could buy stock
in someone's career, I
would buy it in yours.
So he didn't gimme the part,
but I think he was trying to tell me
don't give up, keep going.
- [Jodie] Keep going, yeah.
- Oh My God, I had the same thing.
So I don't even know if people know,
but before I did American Idol,
I tried out for this show called Pop Stars
and it was for a group of, I didn't know,
but I was just paying bills.
But I tried out and they said
you're not right for us
cause you're not for a group.
But the person literally, and at the time,
I was like, is this just you being nice?
But the person literally was like,
I bet you that you're
gonna be somewhere someday
cause your voice is great.
And it was so defeating
cause I didn't make it,
but you think I'm great. What?
Yeah, but it is right.
You're not right for everything, right?
You gotta wait for your moment.
But that's so funny that
that happened to me as well.
I was defeated though. I was like, great.
But your family is from Jamaica.
- Yes.
- I love Jamaica.
So I heard while you here=
- I love Jamaica, who loves Jamaica?
- Who doesn't love Jamaica?
It's like one of those places you go
and you're like, people live here.
Like, you know, we go on vacation.
This is when you start
questioning your life decisions
and why you aren't living
in a certain place.
But it's beautiful there.
But I heard that you ran into
the legendary Grace Jones there?
- Oh my god, yes.
- That's incredible.
First of all, just you
two in the same room.
I don't know if there's enough.
Like that's a lot of
powerful energy happening.
- First of all, I love Grace
Jones. I'm obsessed with her.
- [Kelly] Who doesn't? Yeah.
- She's incredible.
And then secondly, so Grace
Jones is from Spanish Town
which is where my mother's from.
So I'm convinced that we're related.
And when I met Grace, she was
like, we could be sisters.
And I'm like, you see it too, Grace?
- I heard that, did y'all end up dancing?
- Yes, we danced all night together
because she's still such a,
she's a partier. I love her.
She loves to dance and I love to dance
- [Kelly] Cause dancing feels good.
- And I was like, oh my God,
I am on the dance floor with Grace Jones.
- That's a win in life, yes.
Well, I wanna talk about your new movie
cause it's incredible.
So it's Murder Mystery 2.
Tell us about it and who you play.
- Oh my God, it was so
fun doing this movie.
I had an absolute blast!
I play Countess Helene Sekou.
- [Kelly] (indistinct) said it.
- Because that's her energy, mmm.
Some have described her as a villain
but she is definitely not a villain.
- Well it's fun to play
a villain if you are.
- She's misunderstood.
- Misunderstood.
- She's just very specific about, how she-
- That's what a villain would say.
I was just misunderstood.
- And it was just incredible to play with
starring Jennifer
Aniston and Adam Sandler,
who are just like-
- Incredible cast, yeah.
- Legends of comedy.
And so it was so exciting
to do it with them
and be like, oh my God,
these people think I'm funny.
Like I'm in this movie doing this.
But yeah, it's, we get up
to some really fun stuff.